now we want to do a little cast
superlatives with you guys so I've got a
list of questions here tell me the first
member of the adult losers that comes to
mind who is the best-dressed when they
arrive to set before they get into
wardrobe James McAvoy PJ like you stuff
up I mean most likely to spill something
on themselves during lunch or at
crafting me dandy
James ransom I was gonna say PJ that's
James Branson who is the most likely to
throw up on a roller coaster mm-hmm
McAvoy
megalo fly off though I think actually
he'd be riding them the roller goes I
can't I could see him very neurotic yeah
I can see it actually in the film he has
a wonderful love that would fit what
you're talking your vomiting stresses me
out by the way all right the first thing
I throw up I didn't either on that yeah
that just looks like not you're holding
stuff in your mouth like that no that
exists all CP 12 C psi really makes me
feel a lot better
would you rather have to fake vomit in a
scene or fake sneeze sneeze I want to
fake vomit cuz then you've got the prop
fake sneeze it's all just who is the
most likely to get lost in a funhouse I
think Jay Ryan and Jay yah-hey because
he's so played me you'd be so nice to
everyone that was working there excuse
me do you know where to where the exit
is word for word what they said in the
other room to wrap this up who's most
likely to wake up in a sewer
it's me ten years ago James rensen now
you think in a sewer yeah because he
would just be like it's an experience
man yeah yeah I'm gonna feel it yeah
thank you so much for watching this
video don't forget to like and share it
and for more a chapter to coverage check
out Collider calm